[Music]
fun fact about this movie return of the
jedi it was released in 1983
and one of the original directors that
was considered to direct this movie
was none other than david lynch who
would go on to direct
dune in 1984. i can't help but imagine
what david lynch's return of the jedi
would have been like
probably really really weird and totally
incomprehensible like a lot of his stuff
but i i love david lynch don't get me
wrong
so in case you haven't been following
along with the videos i
didn't like a new hope too much though i
respected that it was really the first
thing of its kind
i really enjoyed watching empire strikes
back and so what do i think of return of
the jedi i guess you'll have to wait and
see
so as someone who has never seen this
movie before i'm going to describe to
you what
return of the jedi is about so return of
the jedi opens up on tatooine
you have c-3po and r2d2
going up to jabba the hutt's castle it's
all part of this plan that they're doing
with leia and luke
to free han solo who was given over to
jabba the hutt after he was frozen in
carbonite so they have this plan where
they're pretending to turn
in chewbacca and collect the bounty that
job of the hutt has put on his head
jabba the hutt finally looks good in
this scene because he's not like
horrible
90s cgi for no reason so anyway leia
manages to free
han solo unfree him from the carbonite
they kiss they have a little moment and
then she gets captured and she becomes
slave leia
i feel like i've seen this image of
slave leia like my entire
life but i never really understood what
was the deal like why was she dressed
like that
now i get it she gets enslaved by jabba
the hutt for a little bit
and then luke shows up and then we have
this really cool scene which i've also
seen parodied countless times
of him fighting this monster underneath
the trapdoor called a rancor and it was
really freaking cool so luke defeats the
rancor he escapes
and then it's time for the sarlacc pit
now i couldn't help during this scene
but think
sand worm sand worm sand or and it's
kind of like a sand worm
but it's not really a sand worm it's
just kind of like this
pit thing with tentacles so jabba the
hut is gonna it's gonna throw
luke into into the pit and it's really
really tense
but then luke pulls a fast one and he's
actually hitting his lightsaber
inside of r2d2 so luke frees himself and
starts fighting with
boba fett now i know a lot of people
always talk about boba fett and how cool
he is
but i really don't get it boba fett is
not that cool
from what i've seen i don't know if he
shows up in other stuff but so far like
i don't really get the obsession with
boba fett
i asked on twitter like what's the deal
with boba fett and no one i don't i
don't know
what the deal is i don't know but anyway
while luke is battling this guy
something way more interesting happens
with leia leia
grabs her chains and strangles [ __ ]
jabba the hutt to death
leia strangles jabba the hutt i was not
expecting her to strangle him to death
that is some brutal [ __ ] holy [ __ ] lair
i love leia leia is like my favorite
like i said in my other review for
empire strikes back she's such a badass
she's a boss she's like yeah you got me
in chains right now but i'm gonna
strangle you to death with these chains
when i get a chance and she does
freaking awesome so the whole sequence
of jabba the hut in the beginning was
super exciting it was fun it's a little
bit on the silly side but a lot of the
star wars stuff is on the silly side so
i can't really knock it for that
it was a lot of fun i enjoyed watching
it so after all that goes down luke goes
back to dagobah
and we have this really sad sequence
where
yoda dies and i kind of didn't want yoda
to die
i really thought he would be around for
a little bit longer i felt like i didn't
get enough of
master yoda and he was in empire strikes
back and then he's gone in this one but
then i guess what did i really expect it
was the completion of a trilogy
a curious thing that i've noticed that
star wars has done
is they do the death of the mentor twice
if you count a new hope
obi-wan's death and yoda's death in this
movie
and then curiously enough obi-wan shows
up in this scene as well so they're
definitely
calling back echoing what they did in
the first movie intentionally i think
but anyway yoda dies but not before
telling luke that he already
has everything he needs to succeed and
then obi-wan kenobi's ghost
offers the information that leia
is luke's sister and that he has to go
and find darth vader and defeat him and
resist the emperor in order to complete
his training and become a jedi
so wow a while ago i did a comparison on
star wars
to dune which i researched without
actually watching the movies
and i kind of forgot a lot of the
information the time since doing
that video so having this revelation
come into play was kind of like an oh
yeah moment they're basically latoya
ganima
all right moving on so the alliance
learns that the empire is constructing a
new death star
but they have to take down the shield
before they can attack it and the shield
generator is on the forest moon
of indoor and on the forest moon of
indore we encounter the
ewoks who are like these crazy hairy
little
alien guys they're super goofy and super
weird and funny
uh i really thought the scene was really
funny when they think that c3po is like
some kind of god
that's such a funny thing that happens
in sci-fi
one of my favorite star trek episodes
who watches the watchers
is kind of like a more serious take on
that and you know even like the dune
thing with the freeman is like a way
more serious take on that but you know
that idea
that when technology becomes advanced
enough it seems
god-like or magical to you know
primitive people that haven't seen that
before
so anyway first the ewoks are going to
kill the group and then they start
thinking that c-3po is god so they
decide not to
so the movie takes a very interesting
turn
after luke reveals to leia that
they are brother and sister and
luke goes off and
surrenders to imperial troops and allows
himself to be taken into darth vader
and he tries to to to tempt darth vader
back to the good side
he thinks there is still good in darth
vader
and darth vader says it's too late for
me son and he takes him to the emperor
and we've been seeing the emperor bits
and pieces
throughout the movie but this
interaction with luke
darth vader and the emperor is where
this movie just
shines this is one of the best scenes
in any movie ever one of the best
sequences so as the alliance is on their
mission to
destroy the death star
luke is being tempted down the dark path
by the emperor who reveals that the
alliance is actually headed
into a trap and that this death star
isn't under construction this is a fully
functional
death star and it's capable of mass
destruction already
and all of your friends are gonna die
and he's like strike me down luke
strike me down in anger do it given to
your rage because he wants luke to give
in
he wants luke to lose control
obi-wan told him earlier to bury his
emotions down deep because they could be
used to tempt him
the jedi are all about mindfulness not
necessarily suppression
of emotions but mindfulness
of emotions controlling emotion the sith
are all about giving in to rage and
anger and even
fear it's consumption and chaos
versus balance and preservation so the
emperor is given the order to destroy
alliance ships
while luke witnesses it and it's too
much for him
he tries to swing on emperor
and then vader stops him and then
then we get an amazing lightsaber battle
now the one from the last movie darth
vader like
clearly was way better than luke luke
has learned
some things in the year or so since that
movie i see
in this movie the force is with luke and
he's
he's holding his own against darth vader
getting angry and anger kind of given
into his rage
he takes off darth vader's arm the
emperor comes up all like
yes give in to the dark side luke has
the chance to kill darth vader
then doesn't he say he can't do it
he says i will not puts down this
lightsaber
and the emperor is all like really
really mad and then the emperor is all
like now you will know the true power
off the dark side
freaking lightning comes out of his
hands
and he starts like zapping luke with
this messed up blue
lightning and he's all like it's like
where the frick did that come from
i like the idea of palpatine
having these powers that other people
don't have it's kind of like i know i
mentioned harry potter
in the last video but it's kind of like
how voldemort has like
tapped into all of these other magics
that other people don't know about
because he's
gone under the very very darkest corners
of magic that's what i
imagine that palpatine has done he's
like explore the dark corners of the
force
and he can do things that other people
can't do because he's palpatine
so anyways it looks like luke is done
like palpatine is like totally got him
with this lightning stuff
and then at the last minute darth vader
stops him he picks palpatine up and he
throws him off the thingamajig
saves his son darth vader could not
allow
his only son to be killed which is a
very very real thing
it's believable it's human because as
as as dark as darth vader was
as alien as he seems at time
as as evil as he seems at times as evil
as he certainly is he's killed
a lot of people he's still
ultimately a human and the human in him
could not bear to see his only son be
killed and that's just
strikes me as a very very true story so
luke goes up to his father he removes
his mask
for the first time we can we see darth
vader's face
he is dying and it's a very very
touching moment
and not at all what i really expected
from this movie i really thought that
this was going to end
with luke skywalker killing darth vader
it
subverted my expectations in the best
way sorry david and dan from game of
thrones
so after this the death star gets
destroyed again
and the heroes escape and luke
burns darth vader's body
on a pyre and says his final goodbyes to
his father
all right now to talk about something
that i know is
controversial amongst star wars fans
for some reason and it's kind of
surprising to me now before i watch this
movie
about a thousand people told me that i
was going to hate
the ewoks they said oh the ending with
the ewoks is so
stupid it makes no sense so at the end
of this movie we have
the ewoks helping our heroes overcome
the imperial like technology
walk things and you know helping them
defeat
the empire and their troops inside of
the forest
on the forest moon of endor apparently
a lot of people think this is really
silly surprisingly enough
i don't this totally would happen
you can look this up time and time again
throughout real world history this very
sort of thing
has happened you have technologically
superior invaders
coming into the land of a primitive
culture
and you know getting their asses kicked
this happens because
native societies tend to have
intimate connections with the land they
inhabit they know it
well they have the upper hand sometimes
superior technology just isn't enough
i remember in school we learned a story
of
british soldiers marching into the
territory
of native american tribes they were they
were marching to a battle and they had
these big drums and they were
marching out in the open the natives
ambushed them from the trees and
slaughtered them
you know the british soldiers certainly
had superior technology
but the natives knew their land so
actually i don't think the ewok thing is
stupid
little silly but no more silly than like
the jawas or the
sand people on tatooine i think it
actually fits
huh and you know another thing i like
this movie more than empire strikes back
this was my favorite of the three the
darth vader redemption arc was iconic
that was amazing that was such a great
scene
force lightning so good emperor
palpatine was so cool
when he said the death star is fully
functional i got chills
when he's all like now you will pay the
price for your lack of vision
i died that was so good i loved that
this movie
also had a lot of quiet moments between
characters
i loved the moments that luke and yoda
had in this movie even though it was
super sad
it was great the moment between luke and
leia was great the moments between
han and leia great a lot of people say
this movie's silly but i don't think
it's any more silly
than the rest of them i mean there was a
ridiculous
dance party that was like cgi and
clearly something that was like added
later i don't know what that was
supposed to be
but i'll kind of give them a break for
that i don't know how much of that was
in the original thing
i know these movies have been tampered
with the dance sequence was weird i will
give it that that was such a like
shift in tone i was like not ready i'm
like what is going on
but other than that like this movie was
fun i enjoyed it
if i had seen this when i was a kid i
would have loved it probably
i enjoyed it as an adult so here's the
thing i think this trilogy
for what it is is solid it's a good
trilogy
i think i think when taken as a whole
new hope
empire strikes back return of the jedi
it is a solid
movie trilogy new hope being the weak
link i think
empire strikes back and return of the
jedi clearly were two movies that were
thought about
together or at least i think they were
because they
they share themes and there's threads of
ideas that run through both of them
like when luke has his journey to the
innermost cave
which is actually a term used in joseph
campbell's book
about the hero's journey it's an
incident it's an actual step on the
hero's journey and luke
literally goes into a cave i thought
that scene was about
not striking down your enemy and anger
which was exactly what was going on in
this film return of the jedi it was
exactly that he was meant
not to strike down his enemy in anger
because that would have been giving in
to the dark side and that's not what the
jedi do and that's not who the jedi are
all right so a return of the jedi i
would say that between this one
and empire empire is great but i had
just a bit more fun watching this one so
i'll give this one
an 8.5 and i'll be moving on to watch
the star wars prequels which are very
controversial
um so these will be interesting to see
we'll see how it all started and the
beginnings of the empire and whatnot
and looks like yoda is doing some force
lightning on this so yoda can do the
forced lightning too
so that kind of like disproves my theory
about
palpatine doing dark things in the force
but maybe this movie sucks who knows
anyway thank you guys so much for
watching make sure you like and
subscribe for more of quinn's ideas